what have you learned about yourself
from dating and going on dates I've
learned that I am lovable and sometimes
I feel like I'm not I feel like
everybody relates to that though but I
am lovable I don't know why I'm getting
choked up for a
second you are lovable what is happening
what do you see on an app and that's an
immediate red flag that you don't want
to get to know this person oh my God
like uh mostly on hinge and like the
prompts what's the worst thing you've
ever done and that's the prompt and
they're like being on this app would you
tell me about your favorite date you
ever been on we went to a restaurant had
a nice dinner we went to a bar which was
like a Barcade which is fun and then
there was a band playing would you tell
me about your relationship to dating
this dating make you nervous super
nervous even though I feel like I'm very
outgoing yeah my ideal date is like
dimly lit drinks probably also to calm
my nerves